because I'm thinking about neuralink and
I'm thinking prisons will no longer
exist you will no longer have jail
you commit a crime you get sentenced to
neural link supervision they say we're
not going to lock you up you're not
losing your job you're not being taken
from your family you're going to get a
neural link implant and a suppressor
and the suppressor will stop you from
committing crimes and then after three
years we remove the suppressor
if it's a felony you keep the suppressor
for life and it's like that's due
process it's like you're sentenced to a
life of suppression and like what does
that really mean it means if you start
to get angry or aggressive or try and
Target someone you'll just stop
yeah and then you'll see a guy out in
the street and he'll see someone will
run for the person just go and slow down
and then and then freeze and then it'll
pause him for like 30 seconds and the
woman will be like oh geez and then
he'll slowly start to go backwards and
then be like uh
no more presents well not just that I
was thinking they can either erase
memories yeah or write false memories